[Music]
you are watching The Press previewer
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with Economist for
the eye in Dunt and the daily telegraphs
parliamentary sketch writer Madeleine
Grant they'll be with us from now until
just before midnight so let's see what's
on some of those front pages for you now
well the times leads with William the
Prince of Wales insisting that big Tech
firms must do more to protect children
after the inquiry into the death of the
schoolgirl Molly Russell found social
media content contributed to her suicide
one of these cases also the top story
for the guardian
the telegraph carries an article by the
chancellor Chrissy cuarten in which he
insists the plans he intends to publish
in November will bring public spending
under control
the express hears that the financial
crisis could lead to a sharp drop in
house prices because homeowners will be
forced to sell on mass in order to stay
afloat
the main story for the Ft concerns over
what could happen to the pension sector
when the bank of England's protection
scheme comes to an end in two weeks time
polling conducted for the eye suggests
half of those surveyed who voted
conservative at the last election plan
not to do so next time round
the mail reports on the discovery of
remains it's believed could be those of
12 year old Moore's murder victim Keith
Bennett
that's also the lead story for the star
and for the mirror as well which calls
it the dig for the Lost victim
while the sun claims that television
presenter Phillip Schofield has been
dropped as the face of adverts for a car
firm it comes after he and his this
morning co-host Holly Willoughby were
accused of jumping the Queue at the
Queen's lying in state allegations
they've both denied
reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by Ian Dunn
and Madeleine Grant welcome to you both
let's start with the Telegraph and uh
the the Chancellor's
um attempts at rear Assurance he's
actually written an article in the
telegraph but promising a new commitment
to bring public spending under control
Ian take us into this
yeah attempts is probably the best word
for it
um nothing's changed in the actual
quality that he's putting forward
there's certainly no change of course no
u-turn nothing's changed on the date so
we still have to wait really for another
two months before we're going to see any
detail whatsoever what he's really
intending is to deliver two separate
messages here the first one is he says
I'm not going to do it I don't really
care if things are unpopular by which we
take it things like the 45p rate on tax
it's just he's not going to make any
u-turns there and the second is really
to give us an indication that austerity
is coming now you you don't have to read
tea leaves over the last 24 hours
looking at statements either on the
record or off the record from government
ministers and another on the front of
the Times by Simon Clark who tells us
the leveling up is actually
extraordinarily that we've been living
in a Fool's Paradise over the last few
years something which may have passed
most people by and then the welfare
state is terribly generous and therefore
you know spending cuts are going to have
to come so the career has message the
really core message that quieting is
trying to get over in that Telegraph
piece slightly coded is buckled up
because there's more austerity coming
yes uh and it says that he's doubling
down on the mini budget
um acknowledging that some measures may
not be universally popular but but
insisting that they had no other choice
Madeleine
yes that's the line and it's
it's one of the Curiosities of this last
week is just how extra crumble the the
comms around all of this has been you
know we've had several days where we've
seen neither hide nor hair of the Prime
Minister or many of her ministers you
know it's had a real feeling of people
sort of hunkering down in the bunker and
then coming out very belatedly to issue
this statement which as Ian said is is
not particularly substantial it's just a
commitment to publish something more
substantial
um in November and what I find truly
striking is you know the way that this
was all unveiled on Friday
um somehow the fact that
um the government was also giving you
know an ex very expensive energy bailout
to
um consumers and households the manner
of the unveiling has basically meant
that that has been completely
overshadowed by what is actually a much
smaller worth a lot less
um tax cut for the wealthiest it's it's
completely overshadowed the message
entirely and I think the the kind of
cavalier and abrupt way which they did
that has
um spooked the markets obviously but
it's also alienated a lot of MPS who
might in principle have supported this
um it's difficult for them to defend and
it also shows I think how they're sort
of burning through
um political Capital long-term political
Capital that they will need if they're
going to bring about the kind of
structural reforms things like planning
liberalization
um things that would boost growth
possibly things that would be
controversial like you know building
another Runway Heathrow these are the
sorts of things that you want to do if
you want to if you're boosting growth
um they've now annoyed their MPS so much
that even though in practice they have a
majority of of over 70 I think in
practice it may amount to less than that
because of the way in which
um so many of their colleagues have been
alienated by the last week's events and
the Chance they're certainly sounding um
still very confident in this article but
what do you make of the obr chairman
saying that the initial forecasts uh
that they will give to the treasury
they'll be handed to them next week but
they they're not going to be made public
in
yeah they're being held back so that we
can see it all as a package again in two
months time I mean
the obr throughout its history since
George Osborne set it up has been a
delicate game it's very cautious about
making sure it's independent it says the
things that it's supposed to say it
doesn't stray into politics it's very
diligent about keeping that distance
from the chancellor and until now until
Liz truss walked into Downing Street
chancellors were very good about
treating it with respect you could say
the same thing by the way about the bank
of England when you know Gordon Brown
made it independent he was diligent
about making sure he didn't start
commenting on interest rates he was very
careful to keep that wall there and the
chancellors that followed him behind
them in exactly the same way now trust
has been burning down those walls since
you came in into Power that's certainly
the case with the obr it was dismissed
out of hand when they came in and that
is part of the reason that we have ended
up here the scrutiny that it provides
doesn't just improve the quality of the
proposals being put forward by the
chancellor it is noticed as a signal as
a signal about Risk by the markets to go
okay these guys aren't marketing their
own homework they have people there
independent people there checking what
they are doing so the lack of respect
the dismissal with which it was treated
was part and parcel of the events that
we've seen over the last seven days uh
Madeleine the rising costs of mortgages
um going to affect very very many people
uh the express suggesting that we're
heading for a house price slump
yeah it's it's truly it's truly alarming
I mean
it's really hard to think of a time when
the mortgage Market has deteriorated so
quickly and the amount of chaos and
uncertainty that has has come in its
wake I mean because of the essentially
the the semi-collapse of the market you
now have
many people who are perhaps tempted to
buy or in the process of buying add a
loss of you know what to do next and how
to deal with it and literally overnight
many properties have become in practice
unaffordable and at the same time you
have people who might have been looking
for property or backing out of deals
um and sellers are giving up so it's
just this kind of wholesale collapse
that's happening really quickly perhaps
even quicker than
um during 2000 you know at the time of
the last financial crisis in in 2008 Yes
and then the the express is the quoting
Mass forced sales
um suggesting through HSBC that many
homeowners can soon be paying 5 000
pounds more a year to Simply keep the
roof over their heads
yeah I mean more controllers are going
to suffer and it's good it's it's going
to be covered it's interesting to see
the way it's covered because journalists
typically speaking are in exactly that
demographic that is most effective about
this anyone that's sort of in their 30s
and 40s right now late 30s early 40s the
main conversation that takes place is uh
so what's going on with your mortgage
like how badly are you getting hit right
now and so they're very emotionally
engaged intellectually engage with a
story and they will cover it hard the
thing is everyone's going to lose
everyone's losing from what is happening
here right now if you import products
here in order to run a British business
for instance you are getting hurt right
now the taxpayer is now on the hook for
65 billion in an emergency bailout that
we're doing to prevent a run on pension
schemes like everybody is hurting and
they're hurting on the basis not even
really of the policies themselves you
could have if you'd staggered this right
if you really want to pursue a kind of
drunken reaganite agenda which is
essentially what they've decided to do a
kind of sloppy reaganism you can do that
if you did it slowly and diligently and
planned it out and made sure that you
understood the proposals that you were
putting forward but they didn't they
were just all over the place not even a
basic level of competence not even a
back squeak of competence exhibited by
them and everybody mortgage holders
taxpayers importers everyone's going to
pay yes and the results of what we've
seen over the the last week or so is
that disastrous polling for the
conservatives as detailed by the eye and
not a front page I think they'll relish
reading Madeleine
no I don't think they will I mean the
the kind of numbers that have been
quoted here in the eye half of 29 voters
abandoning the party I mean these aren't
just bad polls these are kind of
potentially existential and you know
it's the kind of the kind of numbers
that would make uh conservative seats
that had previously been regarded as
safest houses
um suddenly coming into play
um and I think for the back bench MPS I
mean there are some interesting MPS
quoted in the um voices quoted in some
of the newspapers tonight
um that uh veteran MPS are saying that
they they have no there's no way that
that they can foresee a victory
um at the next election and you have to
think you know
if you're a toy MP and you're getting
probably quite an onslaught from your
constituents
um even though it seems utterly absurd
that the conservative party would um
eject one prime minister appoint another
and then you know so quickly the
stirrings of mutiny but as I say these
numbers are the kind that almost a kind
of Extinction event for the conservative
party so there's going to be a lot of
muttered whisperings and plotting on
WhatsApp groups um and MPS who looking
at the numbers will think well you know
I'm going to be out of a job and in that
situation they will start to
um well I think it will get a bit Ides
of March if it carries on like that yeah
so they're creating one former Minister
um telling the eye she's finished there
are lots of letters going in we just had
to move on from her quickly now
um sounds like they've made their minds
up Ian
um I mean she is finished there's no
there's no two ways around it I know
what this week was Elemental in
political terms it's the kind of thing
that you talk about in 20 years time you
know in 20 years we'll be sat here and
something bad will happen and we'll be
like oh it's bad but it's not as bad as
do you remember like the Liz trust
budget that's like the obviously the
most apocalyptic project we've ever seen
that's exactly the way that we'll talk
about this so is she going to be
finished in two years at the polling
Booth or is it going to be in one year
by Tory MPS or is it even going to be by
Christmas because I mean at this rate of
catastrophe it is perfectly believable
that they will try and get rid of it by
customers people talk about the 1922
committee and which rules the rules do
not matter like we must understand that
now after the last few months we've had
like they will change the rules whenever
they need to change the rules and if you
need to have cabinet secretaries
resigning to force their hand you do it
and if you vote against the finance bill
you do it and ultimately there are
always ways for you to get rid of a
prime minister if you want to and at the
moment you're looking at the kind of
headlines the polling the sheer just
almost biblical catastrophe that she has
presided over over a period of what
seven days and on that basis I'm it's
pretty clear that they're surely going
to have a go and they do have for me in
getting rid of the leaders can be quite
uh brutal the conservatives in and
Madeline for the moment thank you we're
going to take a break
coming up as an inquiry finds harmful
social media content contributed to the
suicide of the schoolgirl Molly Russell
we'll examine what more big Tech firms
can do to address the problem
[Music]
thank you
you are watching The Press preview still
with me in dumped and Madeleine Grant
taking us through the newspapers let's
have a look at the guardian uh their
headline there social media accused of
monetizing misery and these are the
words of Molly Russell's father who's a
accused the social media firms of doing
just that we've heard today Ian
it's a good phrase it's an interesting
phrase it's the same phrase that's used
um about extremism with these guys which
is essentially about the algorithms I'm
not commenting here on the material
itself that she would
um it's but there is a especially on
YouTube but you get it everywhere in
Instagram
and other places that as soon as you
look at something you'll be showing okay
so this guy likes this so we're going to
show them more of that and over and over
and typically that content becomes more
and more extreme and there's been quite
a few studies that have shown this to be
the case now there's been quite a few
studies showing Pathways of people from
Fairly moderate sort of right-wing
nativist kind of populist right views
into really quite scary far-right views
by following that just the
recommendations of the algorithm and all
of that is based on a simple Market
logic so you like this would you like
some more of this and if you like this
stuff maybe you like the stuff that's
even harder than that stuff what it
demonstrates is that there's no
editorial judgment there there's no
social responsibility there these guys
are not thinking what is our social
responsibility they're thinking how can
we make more money out of this and that
tends to be the pattern that you see in
all these stories often quite desperate
between things like political extremism
and items like this yes and Ian Russell
went on to uh accuse a matter of being
um dragging Molly in to A demented trail
of life-sucking content and the argument
is that that this could have been
prevented he believes that this could
have been prevented
Madeline yes exactly and it's exactly as
Ian said um what was behind this is the
the algorithms kind of propelling her
further and further into this kind of
Vortex of you know awful content
um and in the
um in the exchanges
um in um in the inquest
um Molly Russell's father had particular
I think particular grievance it with the
way that the um representative from meta
uh or as was Facebook
um had been discussing the issues and
showing so little kind of concern and
acknowledgment of
um you know precisely what had been
under underwriting this yes and you know
I think
yes I was just sorry I was just going to
just um summarize um his message to meta
and he says to Mark Zuckerberg listen to
the people who use the platform listen
to the conclusions of the coroner gave
and then do something about it we must
leave it there